[Music]
live from the Caesars Palace sportsbook
in Las Vegas this is the be our bedding
show presented by Caesars Palace
sportsbook we're kicking off the
hundredth season of NFL and the very
first season of the be our bedding show
right now
[Music]
welcome welcome to the inaugural edition
of the be our bedding show along our
bedding insider Kelly Stewart I'm cabby
Richardson Oh Kelly it's been 217 days
since the Superbowl and in that time
Tony Stark saved the universe Tiger
Woods won the Masters and blew to report
build us a studio inside of the Caesars
Palace sports book and what a beautiful
studio it is cabine I will be here each
and every Sunday interacting with fans
in the book and on social @br underscore
betting will provide all the info you
need before placing those last-minute
bets
all right let's kick things off with the
marquee matchups of the week these are
the games that everyone is talking about
first up the Titans are five and a half
point underdogs traveling to Cleveland
to face perhaps the most dead dangerous
receiving corps in the NFL Odell Beckham
jr. drivers Landry how do you see this
game Cal yeah you know I see this game
being a Thursday night game this matchup
now here it is you mentioned Baker obj
and Landry but you know what they do
have to face that six rate Titans fast
defense and on the flip side you have
Derrick Henry facing the twenty eighth
ranked rushing defense of the Browns I
think this is gonna be a really good
game and it's gonna cause a lot of
issues for the Browns backers Mariota is
in a contract here
Titans plus five and a half don't be
surprised if they pull to upsetting
Cleveland all right let's go over to the
NFC least the New York Giants go into
Dallas Jerry's house Ezekiel Elliott
just signed a new contract he's ready to
eat what's on the menu the Giants are
seven point underdogs yeah that scares
me a Zeke is ready to eat cabby but you
know what I'm getting a touchdown in a
division rivalry game week one against
one of the worst ATS coaches in the
country and Jason Garrett 17:33 and one
against the spread as a home favorite
man you know this is a really scary game
to bet you can't have to think about a
lying everything about this Cowboys
defense but just put your blinders on
and do it Cowboys plus 7 is the play
weight you mentioned 80 Jason Garrett
80s what does 80s man against the spread
I guess and then is there a profit for
when Jerry Jones is gonna show up and
just stock the sidelines behind zig-zig
Garrett could you imagine poor Jason how
could you work under the
all right let's go to the game of the
weekend it's the Sunday night er it's
the Steelers at the Patriots they're
five and a half point underdogs and the
the narrative just got a little spicier
because Antonio Brown just signed with
the Patriots although he's not playing
how do you see this one place yeah I saw
him show up in the private jet over here
Jimmy started the shell rock they don't
have him on the field for tonight but
listen I have a personal betting mantra
and that is do not bet against gradient
Belichick in Foxborough - can't do it I
would love to do it Big Ben 34:18 and
three as an underdog in his career but
Tom Brady 62 against 62% against the
spread at home 11 in three straight up
versus Pittsburgh I got to stay away
from this game really I have to listen I
know it's Sunday night everybody wants
to match oh maybe I will put it on a
second half way at PR underscore betting
later on okay nice and and like as we're
here at the Caesar's Palace the setting
for the original hangover I have to
consider the length of the Super Bowl
hangover before I put any money on the
page very good point I think I'm gonna
be leaning towards Steelers alright as
we're just get that real quick I'm gonna
go out into the sports book and find
some some very colorful fans to play
some trivia oh I got all good the first
guy is so incredible I don't and I don't
even know Mike Tyson the Tigers still
here but anyway we're going to give out
some we're gonna give out some PR swag
and we have a some action from this
week's NFL slate our first you I can't
wait to introduce you to this man what
is your name from Josh from Toronto
listen I don't wouldn't you even find
the Buffalo Bills chain my jeans so
funny enough there's actually a shop in
the the Miracle Mile we're current over
a plan of Hollywood they got every team
even the bills turnover chains yeah yeah
so I went saw it I'm like yeah that's
for me this is I really appreciate the
full kit all right are you ready for
some trivia so yeah yeah yeah all right
okay week one which matchup has the most
money bet on it with Caesars Rams and
Panthers Chiefs and jaguars
Texans versus Saints Giants versus
Cowboys what do you think
it's a tough one actually I'm gonna say
be Chiefs Jaguars you are correct sir
well done right listening they love
tactical homes out here here's some PR
swag for you thank you so much
outstanding brother right take it easy
brother good luck with your bets next in
all I see you're repping the Cowboys
University we're just talking about the
Cowboys what's your name or are you from
my name is Cameron from Atlanta Georgia
camera from Atlanta Georgia
Zoe Atlanta Georgia how are you are you
tellin ya I'm a Cowboys fan man I love
people getting paid man sows II signed a
big contract baby so you know begin
money over here okay I got a question
for you which team has the most money
bet on it to win the Super Bowl with
Caesars here your four options the
Patriots the Bears the Chiefs or the
Eagles what do you think my g-man after
that deal that just happened yesterday
I'm gonna say the Patriots the Patriots
[Applause]
that's a great choice hey B don't let me
down man come on man are they doing this
dirty the actual answer is the Kansas
City Chiefs
thanks for playing my dude thank you
thank you and lastly all that I've never
seen this Jersey what's your name sir my
name is Nick and then how long have you
been in Las Vegas I bounce back and
forth between LA and Vegas maybe ten
years okay and then what Jersey is this
and where'd you get it from this is Mike
Ditka limited-edition number 89
my favorite coach of all time right I
just can't grow the mustache ha ha ha
neither can i although it's a great look
Baker Mayfield and Aaron Rodgers big
toured with it a little bit this year ok
ah trooper question for you ok
which player has the most money bet on
him to win the NFL MVP here at Caesars
my friend here your options Richard
Travis key I'll just say I don't know am
i catching rogues
Tom Brady and Baker Mayfield those four
quarterbacks would say you
I want to say Tom Brady listen Tom
Brady's went through them before and
that is a great answer okay
however is not the correct answer the
Carranza is Mitchell too risky submit I
should have known that your bears Jersey
come on come on
I should have pulled that out but now I
know for next time now you know for next
time thank you so much my dude thank you
Oh Kelly did you put any money on
literature Biscay to an NFL MVP I did
not I did not place one single bet on
MVP but if I did it would probably be on
Phillip Rivers here in Vegas everyone
has a good gambling story which is why
we created the B are betting
confessional each week we'll be
featuring betting stories from your
favorite athletes and celebs in our
first his style installment snoop
d-o-double-g tells us about a twenty
thousand dollar wager he made with Mark
Wahlberg and UFC president Dana White
the most I ever worn a sports bets was
twenty thousand cash from Dana White the
CEO of a UFC we bet on the Celtics and
the Lakers meet him and Mark Wahlberg so
he was somewhere in Vegas or something
it was the series was like I think it
was two two and then they were like a
big Boston win you know they got a whole
lot of money so I couldn't be like bit
$10 bet 20,000 all right damn didn't
like that one right so I'm in Vegas one
night you just do Dana White come
through the back of the kitchen like a
mafia boss and bring me 20,000 in cash
and I'm like man don't give me this
money funny binary buddy's gonna start
asking for long you gotta give it to me
what win ain't nobody looking so he paid
me off so that was the most I've worn
but Mark Wahlberg still owe me Johnny my
money market mark let that be a lesson
to you all do not bet with Marky Mark
congrats a snoop on the $20,000 score
and don't forget to finish your betting
confessionals to @br underscore betting
for a chance to be featured on our
social channels I'm just now getting
word though that we have a special guest
joining us caddy
we went over there we got a couple of
special guests we have the iconic Joe
Lewis that brought the brown bomber he
was a heavyweight champion for 12 years
and we also have the electric the
effervescent the always entertaining
six-time Pro Bowler two-time All Pro
Chad Johnson welcome to the BMI dude is
beautiful to be here thank you for
having me my arms ready to get out the
house and you walk out of the house with
cigars at all the ways ok wait listen I
know that all-pro receivers been in the
news all week I got your guy Antonio
Brown how much can you share with us
your conversation with Antonio Brown
when you face time from yesterday you
know I talked to a bee yesterday and
told him what to expect once he gets the
way to moving in I think he already
knows what to expect much against the
mainland there there's no tolerance type
culture I mean he knows that and I'm
looking forward to watching him play how
we keep going to excel
I know that much how did he respond to
me you're like hey this is the patriot
line he knows he knows we all know I
mean throughout the NFL we know what it
takes to be there or to play for that
organization now and I was able to share
that with him and now he was all smiles
and I'm excited to see him get the word
next week okay nice listen this is your
first time in the Caesars Palace because
you know first time in Vegas first time
a big because I don't party I don't club
I don't drink all I do is smoke cigars
and play fifa listen you're you and
you've never met a sports back before no
I don't gamble I'm cheap you cheap which
is unfortunate this outfit is plenty of
books no that's that's sensible my dad
okay listen you're you're a creature of
habit and you have a certain routine on
on those football Sundays do you have
any superstitions before you got out
into the future you know it I had no
football superstitions but I did have to
eat the same meal every morning and I
think that was probably part of the
reason for my success which was one
McDonald's high cakes with sausage large
OJ and sausage Egg McMuffin what do you
need any weight McDonald's before games
through a height of your sport right now
was your fuel that was my cure that
doesn't even make any sense it makes
sense it's not about what you consume
it's all about the skill set listen as
you agreed to make your first-ever
Sportsbet the reason we're here in front
of the Joe
statue the superstition is when you rub
his left glove okay it brings you luck
so before we go to the book yeah have at
it my friend okay let's go what's just
not gonna rub the the right hand this is
responsible for fifty two knockouts
Kelly Chad's gonna make his first-ever
Sportsnet we'll see you soon we'll
reveal Chad's best bet later on in the
show now it's time for a little segment
called minds of the public where I'm
gonna answer the last-minute betting
questions sent to us from the VR
audience
Optimus Prime says I bet the Chargers of
minus three before Luck retired should I
try to middle with the Colts catching
six and a half the short answer is yes
you should you have a nice three and a
half point middle I say go for it the
answer for all those at home going Kelly
what is a middle Optimus Prime has a
Chargers minus three ticket he also has
a Colts plus six and a half ticket if
the game if the Chargers win by four or
five or six he wins both bets
next up drift to hard ass do you think
the Jaguars will cover the spread
against the Chiefs
I sure do as a matter of fact I think
they're gonna win that game outright
sorry Chiefs fans but not only the
reverse line movement in our favor but
the better defense Jaguars now better QB
play under Nick Foles a healthy old line
and Leonard fournette I think they win
that game and last but not least silver
and black wants to know what are your
thoughts on the path and Raiders season
win total after Antonio's Brack Browns
moved to New England
so the Raiders didn't move at all which
was expected in theory a B is not worth
a half a game but the Patriots went from
11 to 11 a half the reason why is
because a B has value on a good team the
public perception is now going to be
higher on the Patriots so the sports
books have to really anticipate these
vets coming in so of course they moved
it a half a point cabbie
what's he doing out there in the sports
book ah listen I'm just I'm just soaking
up the vibes and I'm just getting ready
for football Sunday I've never made a
bet before much like Chad but you know
some of this environment might might
lead me towards the counter but listen
you know I'm a man of the people
so I'm gonna let the fans at the Caesars
Palace sports book bet with dr's money
it's time for the peoples parlay I'm
gonna take three teams for this three
sorry for these three legs other
people's parlay the first person in what
is your name sir and where you from hey
Jimmy from I'm from Pittsburgh that you
wouldn't know it from the shirt though
let's go Browns baby
this is tremendous but what do you even
find this case are you getting booed
we're gonna put these Billy days behind
us here we got faker money Mayfield on
the scene Freddie kitchen Nick Chubb
smiles Garrett not to mention obj are
you kidding me let's do it was this guy
what do you like come on man I just hope
you guys don't fight okay listen can you
help me with the peoples parlay the
peoples parlay yes so I need I need a
team that you feel very compassionate
about they you they you check the board
you feel like confident that they're
gonna win what'd I just say baby Browns
all day minus five and a half at home we
are doing this even Oh Joe agrees let's
go thank you so much man so Browns the
first leg of the peoples parlay I
appreciate that
gentleman what's your name and where are
you from like I like the Chargers cap
Gina help me with the second leg of this
parlay have you had a chance to look at
the board look at the matchups on this
football sir what speaks to you okay not
here here but in Vegas but yeah I like
we got this okay
Thank You Nicole all right got the
Browns and the Chargers as the two legs
of the parlay and the third leg of the
parlay is gonna be helped by what's your
name sir I'm Mike from Pittsburgh your
mic from Pitts is it easy okay nice um
are you are you a fan that that's
emotionally or if you look at the stats
and previews and then you make your bet
I'm big numbers go stick the numbers you
know okay so I'm going with
Jameis Winston not eating any W today
he's taking a loss at home all the 49ers
the Niners yes we're doing it okay Wow
Jimmy goats making a big big come back
here come back player of the year
let me go are you also a fan of his
lifestyle I love it what married date
support are guys like younger the main
seven their kids live in the dream okay
thanks oh you do okay so we got
the brach we've got the Browns the
Chargers and the Niners as the I don't
know why I ask the question about the
lifestyle I knew I was going to get ok
the quick recap Brow's -5 I'm going to
have charges minus six and a half and
the Niners are the underdogs with one
what do you think of my peoples parlay
so I hate it that's ok though sure one I
know sorry guys I wish I wish that they
would let me book this bet I'll just put
it in my pocket keep the money I do not
like any of it actually I can't I can't
even lie you okay fine okay fine
that's my that's the people's part I
went and crowd source the the best bet
my version of investment what is your
best bet Kelly kook Abby are you ready I
am ready I don't know if you're ready
it's like one of the ugliest dollars in
the board you just mentioned you've
never placed a bet if you ready to bet
on this you may hate me by five years
are they the bills it is not the bills
it's almost as ugly as the Redskins but
not quite I'm gonna take the second
ugliest dog on the board in the
Cincinnati Bengals won nine and a half
guys remember we're betting numbers not
teams don't panic here we still have
Andy Dalton who's 11 three and one as an
underdog in September we're catching
almost double digits here with a team
against the team who led the league last
season in penalties in Seattle Pete
Carroll's teams take a little bit of
time to gel and I think week one laying
nine and a half points is way too much
take the 9 and a half with the bangle
eight but Kelly they're playing in
Seattle they got to face you know the
twelfth man Bobby Wagner is a 99 and
Matt in 20 do damien clown is there the
defense is like middle of the road and
we're cool with the bangles
I don't think jenavian is gonna be ready
just yet for that system and the 12th
man of course they're gonna be loud
they're gonna be rocking until the red
rifle throws his first shot a great day
in Seattle what's special guest our
special guest alert back in the book how
was the girl variance in the sports but
we know it was very good it was very
good I'm not a gambling man
but I took what I thought was a safe bet
okay I see two tickets in your hand you
tickets yeah can you show them we bet on
best two teams in NFL can you see is it
clear go here is that Bengals copy
you're so weird about that 12-minute
deepen bangles money line my man the
Bengals to wait straight up you see it
I'm you see I'm sorry I'm sorry we're
gonna win straight up I like I like both
guys confidences I guess I guess we'll
see I'm gonna post up to these outfits
by the time you catch all right guys
thank you for joining us on the
inaugural be our bedding show presented
by Caesars for Thank You Chad Johnson
Thank You Kelly we'll see you next week
I love you call me
[Music]